my mouth is getting careful with your
fingers in your eyes hey what's going on
everybody for first we feast I'm Sean
Evans and you're watching hot ones the
show with hot questions and even hotter
wings and today I'm joined by actor
director Gary Dell'Abate his nemesis
Michael Rapaport in the building how you
doing I'm good I'm good I'm glad to be
here we have 10 wings they get crazy hot
I have 10 questions for you if you get
all the way through 30-second plug is
all yours very big duck what I wish such
high stakes I get the honor of plugging
something yeah you ready first wing
sriracha so I have the first wing yep
oh nothing I'm a big fan of snoops GGN
show and one of my favorite episodes
ever was the one that you were on and it
featured this crazy story about you
seeing the meeting between Tupac and
Snoopy arse time yeah Snoop had
literally just come out it's just right
after deep cover before his record came
out Tupac rolled Snoop Dogg his first
blunt moments after that which I think
should be some sort of national holiday
this is definitely birthday on page
first time Snoop Dogg smoke the blunt
that's like a a pivotal moment in time
there's a photo moments after John
Singleton ice cube in Tupac and I was
like cuz I knew you knew like you knew
it was something special all right
number two Tapatio if that was nothing
this is gonna be another nothing easy
question when the Knicks drafted
kristaps porzingis know like many Knicks
fans you buried and I knew nothing about
you got on the Dan Patrick show and you
buried him again buried why are you like
the rest of these coward Knick fans who
are now dropping to their knees and
kissing the ring I'm saying don't worry
I released 14 points a game but not that
I was right I didn't know who he was it
was a visceral emotional reaction unlike
this hot sauce do nothing to me good god
I saw him at a nickname we made eye
contact he saw me I saw him we
salut to each other and he went about
his way mutual respect
this one is le Yucatec o Caribbean
habanero no problem for you you directed
a great documentary Tribe Called Quest
beat crimes in life and I'd be remiss if
I didn't ask you you know with all the
time you spent with five dog
what's your lasting memory would you
know who would love this sort of love
doing this
oh five dogs he would've loved he would
have been great with this I never saw
him not light up or appreciate when
someone approached him about being fight
from A Tribe Called Quest always was
like peace fam what's up fam you know
love love you know every single time
when he was tired you know going through
house I'm always like when you think I
like the best of New York five dog so
well said pain is good screaming child
hunger is good pain is it were only at
number four number four damn how you
feeling this is none okay all right feed
these two babies babies up spit this out
I want man food you've been in a bunch
of rap music videos jay-z Ludacris Talib
Kweli you know when I did the jay-z
video um you belong to the city
unfortunately it was probably the first
jay-z song and the only jay-z song in
the last 20 years that wasn't a big hit
but before Ben Stiller and for the
bandwagon errs and I love been stolen
and every single other [ __ ] actor I
was in the videos I was [ __ ] with
jay-z then no Bruno and now everybody's
in videos so I'll say that I I'm proud
of that
quality same thing where and when most
of the time for instance complex had
asked me to do this I say where and when
I'm that kind of guy
love it you know if I was a girl you'd
consider me easy are you ready to move
on from oh nothing
many spikes nothing many spikes this guy
here nothing soft who is this guy
microbat alright this is exciting
because this is actually hot sauce
the hot ones hot sauce it's made by her
friends homeboys hot sauces out of
Phoenix old boys hot sauce
homeboys hot sauce it's distributed by
heat mist they can buy it on
fine very big day for hot ones because
now we have her oh you're giving this
[ __ ] these guys more of a plug than I
may or mean this is our show but if I
don't make it through this then the
[ __ ] hot shows gets a plug and I'm
sitting with my dick in my hand and a
napkin in my mouth
well you're cruising through the wings
man it looks like you're not gonna have
a problem anyways your resume is so vast
you probably have over a hundred acting
credits over the last 15 years what's
the most bizarre role you think you've
ever turned down not even a handful is
it one or two things that I turned down
but I would never say that because it
would discredit the people that did it
and I don't think that that's classy and
I'm known for being a classy guy oh yeah
you know I mean I mean like when you say
Michael Rapaport class sophistication
Marco look second 99.9% of the time you
can tell right away if it's gonna be
good bad or garbage literally you walk
on to us you know right away right away
you could tell how people are speaking
to each other the bigger movies are the
ones where I've had that feeling
immediately call my agent like what the
[ __ ] is you just got there I go this is
a [ __ ] mess but you know I'm
fortunate to have been doing this for so
long and continue to get opportunities
to work as an actor and improve as an
actor and grow as an actor I have no
complaints i I tell you one complaint I
have yeah is you're talking about your
hot sauce here here's the deal
and if you go Bruce my mouth with this
well my breath is bad I've rinsed my
mouth with this oh yeah then like
nothing to it oh boy hot sauce this is a
palate cleaner did you at least like it
it's great
let's talk about the I am rapport
podcast for a second it's a hot I make
you angry
it's the iron rapport stereo podcast I
don't know what kind of sounds you got
here the iron rapport stereo podcast
serial podcast I want to name some of
the people that you've gone after
recently and you can just let me know
what your problem is okay gene Simmons
if he doesn't have a hair transplant and
looks like he does and if he does have a
hair transplant he should get his money
back he said rap should die he's one of
the reasons why classic rock went away
do you make up and they were eating dogs
and and and killing pigeons and the
smoke and mirrors because the music
sucked did you ever listen to kisses
Greatest Hits
I just know that yeah I want to rock
that's it there is no Greatest Hits it's
one great hit and a [ __ ] freak show
Oh dinner Bruce wasn't that interesting
and it turns out that Caitlyn isn't
either right I'm over it
the woman of the year doesn't I'm over
at Salman's say what about Donald Trump
Donald Trump is I was amused and
inspired by some of the sort of way he
was talking in a political forum he was
bringing it down to a more um sort of
regular level yeah in the beginning
right but I hate concerns the [ __ ] out
of me you know he was up there talking
about unfolding the loaf you know in his
dick game and all that [ __ ] yo even even
I would know that if you're running for
a political office the president has to
have some sort of poof right that's what
I was thinking like I'm not mr. powers
either like if you and me probably have
similar sensibilities you know this
guy's getting harder and harder to find
funny you know I guess it ain't funny it
ain't cool no more so now at this pain
100 normally when do they take their
first simple water for in five in like
you're way ahead of the curve Savage
you've been able to get work
consistently in this industry over the
course of three decades I see you Palin
around with some serious power brokers
buddies with Bieber but then you get on
this podcast and you'll just tee off on
people like like
on this floor and it's interesting
because there seems to be a lot of
politicking in the entertainment
industry
but somehow you get away with it hey it
is what it is you know I mean we're it's
a comedic podcast I don't think we ever
make it personal I think we keep in a
public sort of persona public they all
things that are sort of it's like we're
not doing anything original I are you
notice my lips are strong don't think my
lips are working now Wow I'll hang go
ahead man can I eat the pain yeah yeah
yeah I already did
how is it it's not good and the front
nine of this of this challenge we're
very chirpy and now I see that it's
leveled off a little bit why I can't
throw my lips so that's going Tony I
thought you're a tough Joey Fatone from
NSYNC came in here last night and was
sweating a lot less than you well that's
great then the [ __ ] I'm the follow up
got guest - Joey Fatone [ __ ] my life I
know thanks for telling me that I know
that you're a big Real Housewives fan
yes that Lana's your favorite right or
do you like the other ones Atlanta and
New York and you've known Dame Dash
since you were a little kid what do you
think of the news that I read yesterday
that they're thinking about replacing
Kim fields with Stacey - and Real
Housewives of Atlanta
are they really yeah what do you think
of that move I don't like that why not I
think the thing that's fascinating and
good about is you don't know these
people to begin with and obviously y'all
man
that's my answer that's my short answer
y'all can you cue music Tupac in a
moment we thought we do it the real
affinity to reseal to say don't
what's this [ __ ] Matt dog three five
seven why would why would you want to
eat this somehow it got into my nose man
it gets all over you know I got a
deviated septum I do and a lot of
excuses a lot of excuses I'm not [ __ ]
with you now man you're in Woody Allen's
new Amazon series I need a napkin cuz
I'm afraid that I'm gonna burn my
[ __ ] eyeball and you're alongside
Miley Cyrus whose public persona very
eccentric very colorful very loud when
you met her did you meet the mileage
expected to meet or was it a totally
different person entirely totally cool
um very charismatic sweet totally
professional um nice to everybody and I
think she's gonna be fantastic in the
Woody Allen Amazon series number you're
just chucking wings around the studio it
seems like so long ago it seems like a
lifetime ago I wanted to talk about
reality shows with you you want to keep
talking about reality shows I can't talk
about [ __ ] do you [ __ ] with Vanderpump
rules [ __ ] with Vanderpump rules Real
Housewives of Beverly Hills Love & Hip
Hop Atlanta I love in here pop in New
York he want me to do my top 5 I was
doing top 5 Dead or Alive give it to me
Nene's the center nene leakes my point
guard is bethany my shooting guard is
the Puerto Rican princess sister
Patterson number 4 and I'm gonna go with
Porsha Porsha from Real Housewives of
Atlanta to film I coach coach
Stevie J Stevie J that's a good clean
[ __ ] great
Ray J would have been a good coach Ray
J's the [ __ ] GM do you know what he
does better than any guy in the history
of the world
his [ __ ] dollars buck Wow
I can't see like it's like smokey this
is where heroes are made you know this
lad is doing this why am I here things
are good they're good you were having a
good morning they know my life on my
world warming you didn't need to [ __ ] it
out of it [ __ ] am i doing here
you're such an NBA fan I got to drop
some names on you so I can get some snap
judgments off you from those okay good
but I wanted to be coincide asked a
question I'll take the bike cuz I'm a
[ __ ] around that's what we're doing the
snap in the [ __ ] toilet LeBron James
unfollowing the Cavs on Twitter and
Instagram why why would he do I do you
follow complex media yes okay if you
won't follow complex media it would be a
thing okay a big thing right bigger than
the Buddha LeBron James then way bigger
when that little reporter meekly asked
him about not following the Cavaliers he
acted like he shouldn't be asking him
that question I didn't like how that
reporter was like excuse me I'm sorry
that I have to ask yeah I was like a
dude just ask a question [ __ ] what
the [ __ ] and then the other thing about
that is LeBron answer that [ __ ] class
answer the question you didn't follow
him you know everybody's watching you
Steph Curry he's the best he's so good
so unique and last one cuz I have to ask
you a Carmelo I feel bad for Carmelo at
this point I say they should they should
cut him and and and let him go where he
should go he deserves better than he
stayed in you don't have to eat that
[ __ ]
well you made it to the top of the
mountain it was a hot take back to you
just as I hoped it would be the sauces
kind of kicked your ass at the end but
you made it all the way through and
that's gotta count for something
30 seconds let the people know I do not
let them know anything I let him give
you ask me about everything I've shamed
myself my family people that call me
friends doing this [ __ ] have you
actually got to the point where someone
plug something after this usually people
went out there yeah exactly like they
don't get all the way through and just
to like I do it for the love of the
sport
I'm Rappaport stereo podcast Amazon
Series Woody Allen's new Amazon series
and then if you need them for a rap
music video just call him and he's there
if it's good gotta be good and I gotta
just do any rap video
you
you